bonjour à tous bienvenue ont résumé des
ondes 3 et 4 du match de championnat du
monde dans cette troisième partie
fabiano caruana ravel et blanc contre
magnus carlsen et ils ont rejoué une
sicilienne russell immo comme dans la
première partie
voici la position dans laquelle nous
atterrissant au 14e coup donc les noirs
ont joué tout reprend à 5 3 5 pour
récupérer la colonne ouvertes les blancs
auraient dû probablement au lieu de
jouer le coup fou des deux directement
prendre la tour on a cinq dur 3,5 d'un
prompt à 5 et ensuite tous les deux de
façon à attaquer évidemment la dame 1 à
5 et à l'obliger à défendre son pion à
eux cinq du coup elle serait obligée de
revenir ans et cette dame c'est cette
probablement et maintenant dames 1 1
permettant d'attaquer ce pion aux 5 et
donc de rentrer sur la colonne ouverte
afin d'attaquer
par la suite le pion en bessette avec
l'aide de la tour dames à 1
on peut envisager cavaliers 17
damas 7 et par la suite par exemple le
coutour en a un pour attaquer le pion
bessette orbea pardon pour attaquer le
pion bessette
curieusement ne fabiano caruana n'a pas
pris la tour il a joué fou des deux
camps sont peut-être que ça revenait au
même après évidemment tout reprend 1
d'un point et nous obtenons la position
mais les noirs peuvent conserver cette
colonne
en remettant la tour on a huit bien joué
tour à 8
et ici la position est évidemment
différente les noirs us aussi contrôler
la colonne ouverte donc les blancs ne
dispose pas de cette colonne à lui tout
seul
ont ils ont quand même une position un
peu plus agréable après le coup d'un b 1
me récupère économie ouverte qui décède
à mambé 4 pour éventuellement faire une
batterie avec la deuxième tour la tour e
1 qui viendraient en b1 toujours pour
attaquer le pion bessette mais aussi
avec la dame peut être essayer de
rentrer dans le camp des noirs sur la
case de 7 afin de clouer le cavalier en
une option qui aurait pu être rejoué un
peu après nous allons voir tour et fait
8 va par des noirs pour empêcher
l'entrée de cette dame fous ces trois
pour continuer la pression sur le pion
au sein avec les blancs disposent toutes
leurs pièces sur les cases les plus
actives bessin accès un bon coup pour se
débarrasser évidemment du pion à rire et
le pion bessin avec maintenant est
protégé par le pion c6 il ne risque plus
rien le pion c6
elle ne sera pas attaquable avant un
moment aux classes il n'y a plus
énormément de possibilités pour les
blancs dans cette position à part
éventuellement rentrer dans cette
variante tour prend la 8 e reprend à 8
hélas il n'a pas osé y rentrer en jouant
peut-être le ku'damm en un set
les blancs auraient pu gagner un pion
mais en donnant beaucoup d'initiatives à
l'adversaire dames 7 qui permet de me
menacer le pion aux 5
mais ce n'est pas si grave parce que on
peut quand même joué le coup par exemple
fois f6 pour attaquer la dame et surtout
prend 1,5
donc la hyène surcharge le cas vaillant
17 et cloud et si le fou m6 prend la
dame en recettes et bien le fou au sein
et qui prend là d'annoncer cette et les
blancs ont gagné un pion mais les noirs
peuvent donner un pion d'une meilleure
façon
en reprenant le fond à saint cloud prend
1,5
cavalier prend 1,5 d'un prend 1,5 d'un
prend 17 et tour à un coup forcer les
blancs sont pratiquement obligé de
prendre pour croire d'un prend un échec
rouages de et dames c3 la dame qui
revient défendre son puits en c6 est
attaqué du même coup le pion ces deux
indéfendable dans cette finale des dames
et blanc n'ont aucun avantage même faire
attention parce que les noirs risque de
créer un pion passé en b 5
donc du coup il ne joue pas cette
variante ils préfèrent échanger les
tours en jouant tour à 1
au 20è couture point fou prend à damas
est ce sont les noirs qui récupère la
colonne et qu'ils vont obtenir une
initiative préfou ces trois dames à de
l'ademe qui rentre dans le camp des
blancs ici les blancs n'ont pas trouvé
mieux que de d'échanger les dames et de
rentrer dans une finale terne pour c'est
qu'ils allaient faire nul très
rapidement pourtant les noirs vont
exercer une pression jo mais la partie
rapidement jusqu'à arriver dans une
position relativement critique après le
coup ses cinq fautes 3 les noirs avaient
la possibilité de créer peut être un
pion passé avec b quatre oursons
n'aurait pas suffi pour gagner mais en
tout cas les noirs mettre la pression
dans cette position et continue à jouer
un tout petit peu il ramène son roi en
recettes finalement les blancs vont
réussir à obtenir la nulle part il va y
avoir beaucoup des champions et il va
forcer une finale nul théorique avec
vous allez voir après cavaillé 3 au 44e
courroye c5f quatre ans là les blancs
échange un maximum de pions c'est ce
qu'il faut faire quand on joue en
défense de pro f 4g pour un f4 fou à 5
pour éviter la fourchette parce que sur
le court wade 4 tout de suite avec
avaler ces deux échecs qui permettait
aux cavaliers de prendre le flou donc
fou à 5 et f5 pour éliminer encore un
pion j'ai point f5 et le bon coup
cavaillé prend ses quatre sacrifice de
cavaliers roi pensaient qu'à peu près f5
les blancs ont éliminé tous les pions
noirs il ne reste plus que 1 c'est
celui-là ne suffira pas parce que il va
faire dame sur une case blanche le pion
h qui est à la bande et le fouet de
cases noires on s'est peut-être vous
savez peut-être que la finale
roy fouet pions h quand le pion en neuf
et dames sur 1,15 opposé au fouet nul si
évidemment le roi de défense le roi
défensive et sur la case de promotion
évidemment les noirs ne peuvent pas
l'empêcher donc ici ils ont conclu la
nulle dans cette partie finalement petit
avantage au départ pour fabiano caruana
avec les blancs mais après il n'a pas
obtenu grand chose dans cette partie
nous allons passer tout de suite à
deuxième partie doit plutôt à la 4e
évidemment du match dans laquelle magnus
carlsen à l'eiblen cette fois une partie
anglaise une partie anglaise nous
aboutissons donc au 14e coup les noirs
viennent de jouer ces six et les blancs
ne continue pas leurs plans alors que il
avait avancé les pions en a quatre et b4
un beau duo de pions il aurait pu
probablement continuer leurs plans en
avançant le plan b 5 de façon à faiblir
un pion alors c'était un peu risqué dans
le sens où après le coup b5 les noirs
pouvaient choisir de prendre le puits en
bessin qu'avec le plan c 6 et 6 pour b5
été le meilleur goût âpre en bessin et à
5 se créant un pion passé éloigné donc
attention évidemment à la finale on sait
que les pions place et éloignées en
finale c'est très dangereux
ça pourrait même être un pion pas ses
protégés si le pion bessette arriver à
le défendre en jambes et 6 pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas puisqu'on
a le fou sur les régionales qui cloue là
le pion et donc les blancs pourraient
après le coup à 5 jouer damas quatre par
exemple afin de lier les tours d'activer
leurs dalles et dans les autres partis
puisqu'ils on est encore dans le milieu
de partie les pions centraux ont quand
même plus d'importance que le pion de
l'est lice y en a cinq
donc avec la paire de fou peut-être un
peu mieux placés chez les blancs il y
aurait un petit avantage en tout cas
peut-être c'était la seule façon
d'espérer de faire quelque chose dans
cette partie qui va être assez terrain
après le coutour 20 donc quinzièmes
couteau rollin l'idée était probablement
d'avancé
le pion en 2 4 protégé par la tour et
ensuite de faire le jeu de pions avec le
coût des quatre de façon à essayer de
continuer à avancer le pion à 4 après la
disparition du pion e5 là les noirs on
joue un bon coup probablement un peu
inattendu fou 17 bon développement du
fou assez passif on al'impression
pourtant il ya une idée derrière
si les blancs maintenant joue le coup à
4 les noirs jouent ces cinq de façon
donc à contrôler la case en d4
donc là les blancs intérêt se
débarrasser du pion c'est sans accident
ils vont rester avec un pion à rire et
en d3b français 5 fu prend ses cinq
tours 37 c'est un sacrifice de clients
de la part des noirs et là le joli coup
dams et 8 permet d'attaquer la tour non
protégés et de viser aussi le fou non
protégés en c3 avec l'attak elle a
découvert du fou avec fougue grand f 2
échecs
donc si la tour revient en b3 évidemment
ça c'est pas bon parce que sur tourbe et
iii nyha le coup fou prend 1,4 avec
l'enfilade on voit à quoi a servi
finalement le foufou 17 finalement pour
attaquer ce pion et si les blancs jouent
le ku'damm b3 pour défendre la tour est
alors pas fou prend à 4,7 fois parce
qu'on aurait une attaque en f 7 mais
simplement le couffo et 6 et la dame va
se retrouver en surcharge
elle va pas réussir à défendre tout le
monde en même temps
ici par exemple si la dame via en p2 on
pourrait avec les noirs même faire le
coup fou à trois puisque la dame doit
défendre la tour donc si elle prend le
fou les blancs perdrait une qualité un
pas oublier aussi le fou c3 qui n'est
pas protégé donc un joli coucou 17 au
15e coup qui permet d'éviter tout
simplement le plan des blancs les blancs
qui se retrouve un peu sans plan 16e
coup et 3 donc
il attend un petit peu bon je veux 4 il
préfère rester souple mais là les blancs
non plus d'initiatives après damev 6 x 4
f 5 tranquillement les noirs propose les
changes du show le fort fou blanc qui
est très important pour attaquer les
pions de l'ale damme 6e vous disparaît
et les blancs n'ont plus de pression
pour pour attaquer ses pions il aurait
pu essayer de le conserver peut-être on
pensait et il a joué dame f3 et on
pensait peut-être coupe ou g2
éventuellement mais tout simplement
dames 6 pour échanger le fou avec vous
h3 et si les blancs fou h1 les bleu et
noir peuvent de toute façon centralisée
leur tour en faisant tour à des 8 et et
les blancs n'ont aucun avantage ici et
même le pion détroit évidemment sera
faible donc y rentrer il va rentrer avec
dame f3 dans une finale complètement
égal après fou prend le cadre d'un point
réussie j'éprouve 6d prend 1,4 on
pourrait se dire que les noirs ont
quelques affaiblissement c'est vrai
alors que les pions doublé et le pion
isolé en chaussettes mais il n'y a aucun
moyen d'en profiter avec les blancs on
peut pas les être prié et il n'y a pas
de deux pièces pour venir attaquer ses
pions tandis que les noirs de leur côté
ont quand même trois pions sur les dames
une majorité de pions qui leur permettra
de créer un pion passé les blancs vont
devoir empêcher la création du pion
passé après b5 bien jouer y met les
pions sur case blanche
étant donné qu'il a le fou de cases
noires donc le bon fumay main puisqu'il
peut attaquer le pion le pion b4y six
tours d un attaque le fou il s'en va
tout simplement faux huit fois fuite
apprend bessin avec apprend b53 g2 on va
mettre la partie jusqu'au bout parce
qu'elle va finir assez vite taureaux des
huit tours d'essai un roi g7 four 1 les
blancs tentent de faire pression sur le
pion ces six tours dé 6,8 tour ces deux
voilà avec l'idée de doubler les
toujours sur le clan ses 6 mai une
contre attaque de les
de la part de noir avec tour à 4 bien
jouer il faut mieux activer les pièces
plutôt que rester passif tour à 4 hélas
il est blanc ou ajouts tour c'est un les
noirs prennent le plan b 4 et obtiennent
leurs pions passé donc ce serait même
dangereux pour les blancs qui a rien à
faire les bleus ont joué jusqu'au 30e
cours ou en f3 h5 peut-être une
possibilité ici avec le coup j'ai quatre
pour essayer de créer un pion passé je
prends gk3 pranger 4 avec le pion pas ch
simplement le problème ça c'est que le
roi se retrouve sur une case d'échec les
noirs pourraient tout simplement
échanger les pions engeance et 5 des
français 5 pour penser saint-victor
pensée 5 france et cinq top 30 des cinq
tours prend à eux quatre échecs et après
par exemple 3 f 5 tours c4 voilà on a
échangé un maximum de pions et a
pratiquement aucune chance de gagner
cette partie même si encore un tout
petit plus peut-être pour les blancs ici
les blancs ont joué 28 3 2 3g 6h 3f cinq
ans les noirs en se débarrassent de leur
affaiblissement 2.153 points f5 f3
fawcett leucate échec 3,6 food est de
fous des six est tombé c1 et là nul a
été conclue donc dans cette quatrième
partie
aucune partie assez terne ici un pad
avantages obtenus par l'un ni par
l'autre en tout cas les noirs qui dont
chaque partie obtiennent finalement des
positions correct merci d'avoir suivi
cette ce résumé de ces partis 3 et 4 et
là je vous dis à bientôt pour un
prochain résumé